y tan venido anticipándose desde hace
semanas a este día y había dicho que no
veía de importancia a estas nuevas
sanciones ni que le preocupaban y de
hecho había dicho que ésta posiblemente
sería una nueva victoria iraní en la
arena diplomática internacional y esto
se debe a que muchos países
especialmente aquellos países aliados de
washington y que también fueron
firmantes del acuerdo nuclear como lo
son francia inglaterra y alemania han
declarado que estas medidas de eeuu son
ilegales porque como recordamos y eeuu
se retiró del acuerdo en el 2018 y esto
lo ha citado el mismo ministerio de
exteriores mohamad ya va a salir que
cita alguien fuera consejero de
seguridad de la casa blanca john bolton
un hombre cuyas políticas anti iraníes
son reconocidas y que reconoce que eeuu
ya se había retirado del acuerdo aún así
irán es consciente de que eeuu puede
imponer unas sanciones unilaterales y
poner presión en la comunidad
internacional para re imponer estas
sanciones especialmente él
con la venta y compra de armas este
embargo se acabó el próximo 18 de
octubre para irán que ya ha dicho que
ellos son poco compradores de armas pero
que si lo hacen lo harán a rusia y china
países firmantes del acuerdo y que
obviamente están en contra de las
políticas de eeuu